SETH VARGO: All right.
Hello, everyone.
Perfect.
How's everyone doing
this afternoon?
Great.
Welcome to Hybrid 200,
Securing Kubernetes' Secrets.
My name is Seth.
I'm a developer advocate.
I work on the Developer
Relations team here at Google.
ALEX TCHERNIAKHOVSKI: Hi.
I'm Alex Tcherniakhovski.
I'm a security
engineer at Google
working on Google Kubernetes
Engine Security team.
SETH VARGO: Great.
So everyone clap for Alex.
He's going to leave
the stage now.
He's going to come
back in a little bit
and show us some
really cool live demos.
Who's excited?
The rest of you don't
like live demos?
Great.
So in order to set some common
ground, I know some of you
are probably security
professionals
and this might seem a
little bit repetitive.
But I want to make sure that
everyone is on the same page.
So I want to start by
talking and answering
a very simple question.
What is a secret?
So for the purpose of
this talk, a secret
is a credential, a
configuration, an API key,
or some other piece
of information
that is required for an
application either at build
time or at runtime.
So some examples here might
be like a database username
and password, a Twitter
API key, any type
of secret or
sensitive information
that the application
needs to run.
And that begs the next question,
which is why do we care.
Why should we just
not use social media
as our secrets management tool?
Why don't you store your secrets
in publicly available tweets?
Well, it turns out that secrets
are an attractive target
for attackers.
Secrets often protect
sensitive information,
like personally
identifiable information,
credit card numbers,
Social Security numbers,
passport numbers, or they
protect access to business data
business intelligence data
like analytics and reports
that could damage your business
or give your competitors
an advantage.
But then you couple that
with how easily credentials
are leaked.
If we look at any of the
recent security incidents,
we've seen access keys leaked
in a public repository because
of a small mistake
from a developer.
We've seen improperly
secured access
to a dashboard or an interface
allowing privilege escalation.
It's very easy for us to
leak these credentials
and expose secrets
unintentionally.
And then third, most
secrets actually
have more permission
than they need,
particularly when we're
talking about IAM credentials
or identity and access
management credentials.
And that's because when
you're a large startup,
it's just much easier to
give everyone root access,
because I don't
know what they're
going to need in a week or two.
Right.
I don't want to have
to go through that.
I need to move quickly.
And then oftentimes
security is an afterthought.
So when you combine
these three things,
you have something that accesses
customer data or business
data that's easily leaked and
has overly broad permissions.
It's an attacker's
like best playground.
So this is why we
need to invest effort
in protecting our secrets.
And there are four key ways in
which we protect secrets today.
The first is auditing.
We verify all of
the use and access
of individual secrets in some
type of centralized system.
This allows us to apply anomaly
detection or machine learning
to find out whenever a secret is
being accessed out of the norm.
Second, we use encryption.
All of our data should
be encrypted in transit
with TLS and at rest with
the most secure algorithm
for your use case
and your industry.
Third, we should be rotating
both secrets and encryption
keys regularly.
In addition to a regular
schedule of rotation,
we need a break glass procedure.
What happens if right
now we leak a credential?
How quickly can we
rotate that credential
across our infrastructure?
Right now we leak an API key.
How quickly can we revoke
and replace that API key?
So we need both
planned rotation,
which decreases our
surface area for an attack,
and we need immediate rotation
in the event of an emergency.
And fourth, isolation is key.
We want to separate where
secrets are stored from where
secrets are accessed.
That way an attacker has to
compromise multiple systems
and escalate privilege multiple
times in order to gain access
to that plaintext information.
For the purposes
of this talk, we're
going to be focusing on that
second component, specifically
encryption.
Now that doesn't mean that the
other three are less important,
but I only have 40
minutes so we're
going to focus on encryption.
There are multiple
layers of encryption.
You might have things like
encrypted file systems
like FileVault, self-encrypting
hard drives, et cetera.
But you might also have,
say, a machine level
encryption, or service
level encryption,
or app layer encryption.
And we recommend that you
always use at least two layers
of encryption for your data.
Now on Google Cloud,
all of your data
is encrypted at rest by default.
No configuration necessary.
But you may want to apply
additional layers of encryption
to your data.
Specifically, you may want
to leverage application layer
encryption.
Application layer
encryption is applied
at one of the earliest possible
stages of the data's lifecycle.
Secrets are encrypted before
they leave your application
or service with keys
or encryption tokens
that only your
application knows.
So in this way only
your application
or only the critical
components of your system
see the plaintext value.
This enables very granular
protection of data.
You can use a different
encryption key
for each piece of customer data.
That way if an attacker
is able to brute force
that encryption key
or the decryption key,
that same key will not work for
another piece of customer data.
And third, this
protects the data
as it moves
throughout the system.
So if I have a hard drive and
that hard drive is encrypted,
if I mount that hard drive
and decrypt it somewhere,
if an attacker has
access to that hard drive
they have access to all
of the plaintext data now.
But by leveraging
application layer encryption,
as I move my secret data
throughout the system,
it remains encrypted regardless
of the underlying storage
mechanism, whether that's
memory, a hard disk, or a thumb
drive.
In the context of Kubernetes,
application layer encryption
means that the
Kubernetes API server
is responsible for performing
the crypto operations.
So in addition to
your application,
your pod, your service,
the Kubernetes API server
also has privilege to see
those plaintext secrets.
And we advocate for
defense in depth.
Again, use multiple
layers of encryption.
Use application layer encryption
combined with operating system
layer encryption, things like
secure boot and hard drive
encryption, et cetera.
So now let's talk
about Kubernetes.
The Kubernetes
default installation
is not encrypted by
default. So today,
if you were to download
the open source
distribution of Kubernetes and
start up a Kubernetes cluster,
regardless of cloud provider,
regardless of infrastructure,
the underlying secrets
are not encrypted.
That means that anyone
who has access to ETCD
or a backup of ETCD has access
to all of your plaintext--
all of your secrets
in plaintext.
Let me show you what
that looks like.
Here I have a credit
card or a piece of data.
I'm using this image to
show that this is a secret.
As a user or as
an application, I
give that piece of secret
data to the Kubernetes API
server when I say
kubectl- create secret
or the associated API call.
The Kubernetes API server
then base64 encodes that data
and writes it to ETCD.
I saw someone smile.
They got my base64 joke.
So the app submits the
secret to Kubernetes.
The API server pushes that
into ETCD into plaintext.
That means that if an
attacker has access
to the master node,
an online ETCD
server, or a backup
of the ETCD database,
all of your Kubernetes secrets
are available in plaintext.
Again, this is a default
Kubernetes installation,
regardless of cloud,
regardless of infrastructure,
the open source
distro out of the box.
This is called encraption.
Encraption is what happens
when you confuse encryption
with encoding.
And my goal here is not
to make fun of Kubernetes.
Right.
Kubernetes is an
amazing product.
And they've made great
strides to improve
the overall security.
So while this is
the default setup,
let's talk about just how
easy it is to extract secrets
and then I'll talk about
some of the improvements
that Kubernetes has
made to make it easier
to secure your secrets.
So if we could
jump over to the--
wow, you're ahead of me.
Perfect.
Now I pull out my cheat
sheet because I'm only human.
All right.
So what I have here is I'm
using a minikube, which is just
a local Kubernetes cluster.
And I have the base default
installation of the latest
version of Kubernetes.
And what I'm going
to do here is I'm
going to go into
this folder and then
I'm going to show you
the command that I'm
going to be running here.
So I'm going to create a secret.
I'm going to use this default
cluster that I've created.
And then I'm going
to create a secret
where I have a key value pair.
The user name is
sethvargo. and the password
is very secure
secret in leet speak.
So let me go ahead
and run this now.
So run bin
create-secret-default. And now
I've created that secret.
So as I was showing before, this
is a default Kubernetes setup,
which means it's stored
in ETCD in plaintext.
So let me show you what
that looks like if I
access the default secret now.
You'll notice that I get back
some additional metadata here.
Right.
I get back almost like
a binary representation.
There's some additional
metadata in here.
But most importantly
right there,
I've highlighted on the screen,
that's the plaintext password.
That's the plaintext username.
All of that information
that I supplied
is in plaintext in ETCD.
Very easy for an attacker
to extract that information
and escalate privilege
in my system.
So let's go ahead and jump
back to the slides now.
Perfect.
Now before we talk about
some of the improvements
that Kubernetes has made,
let's talk about this concept
called envelope encryption,
because it's very important,
because it's the underlying
principle for how Kubernetes
secrets encryption works.
So envelope encryption is this
idea of keys all the way down
or turtles all the
way down, if you will.
There are three
pieces that we're
going to talk about here today.
Again, we have our data, which
was represented by this credit
card icon.
We have a data
encryption key or a deck
represented by a red key.
And we have a key
encryption key or a kek
represented by a green key.
Now, when we want
to encrypt data,
we take the data encryption
key, the red key,
and we encrypt the data.
So we generate a key and we
encrypt the data with that key.
And that produces
encrypted data that
is encrypted with our red
key, our data encryption key.
Then we take our
key encryption key
and we encrypt our
data encryption key.
So you'll notice
here on the slide
I have the credit card, which
is encrypted with the red key.
And then I have the
data encryption key,
which is encrypted with the
green key encryption key.
We then take both of
those pieces of data
and we put them together,
implementation details aside,
and we store them side by side
in some type of storage back
end, file system, database,
whatever it might be.
And the idea here is
that each piece of data
has its own encryption key.
We generate a new red
key, a new data encryption
key for each piece of data, and
that that data is maintained
by a-- is encrypted by a
key encryption key, which
has its own rotation schedule.
When we want to
reverse the process,
the encrypted blob is
separated into its two parts,
again implementation details.
The key encryption key decrypts
the data encryption key bits.
That then gives us the
plaintext data encryption key.
We then take the plaintext
data encryption key
and decrypt the remaining
bits to give us back
the original plaintext data.
This is a very
rudimentary and very quick
overview of how envelope
encryption works.
The key here is--
if y'all are not up
for jokes, it's fine.
The key here is that
each new piece of data
is encrypted with a new
unique randomly generated key
and then we have a
regular rotation schedule
for our key encryption keys.
So maybe that's monthly,
or weekly, or quarterly
depending on your threat
model and your requirements.
So there are some best practices
for envelope encryption.
We want to generate unique
data encryption keys.
So each piece of
data is encrypted
with its own high
entropy unique key.
This allows us to do really
cool things like crypto-shred.
So if we revoke our
key encryption key,
that top level key, all of
the data encryption keys
are now irrecoverable
by traditional means
because they were
encrypted with that key.
Additionally, we can rotate
our key encryption keys on time
based intervals or in the
event of an emergency while we
rotate the data encryption keys
each time we modify the data.
So this provides a
very scalable way
to do cryptographic operations.
So now, let's go
back to Kubernetes.
So Kubernetes 1.7
made its first attempt
at solving this problem by
introducing a new configuration
option for encrypting secrets
at rest before they enter ETCD.
And that looks like this.
So this is what we call an
encryption configuration.
And you'll notice inside
this encryption configuration
I'm specifying an
encryption provider.
In this example, it's
an AES-CBC provider.
And I'm giving it the basics for
encoded encryption key I take
this encryption configuration.
It's a YAML file.
I load it onto my master node
or my Kubernetes API server.
I then start or restart
my Kubernetes API server
by passing in this encryption
provider configuration option.
I give it the path
to that YAML file.
And now we're good to go.
So let me show you what this
looks like in this new model.
So going back to our
original diagram,
I have my credit
card, my secret data.
I give that to the
Kubernetes API server.
Again, the Kubernetes API server
does see the plaintext here.
But the Kubernetes
API server then
delegates to that encryption
provider configuration.
The encryption provider
configuration encrypts the data
before writing it to ETCD.
So we have random
bytes of data in ETCD.
So this means if an
attacker had access
to an online ETCD database or
a backup of the ETCD database,
they would not be able
to recover the plaintext
by traditional means.
But what if an
attacker had access
to the master VM, a full disk
backup of the master node
or the Kubernetes API server?
Well, if an attacker
has access to that,
that encryption configuration
is on that same node in a file.
It's in that YAML file
that I showed earlier.
So if an attacker is able
to gain access to the VM,
they have access to the
keys that encrypted the data
and you haven't actually
improved your security posture.
So from a threat
modeling perspective,
this actually wasn't any better.
But it was a step in
the right direction,
because now the community
started thinking,
hey, we should actually
be encrypting our secrets
and this is the way
that we should do it.
So there are a number of
drawbacks with this approach.
The first, you have to
generate your own keys.
You need your own
high entropy source.
You need to understand
key algorithms.
what is it like.
What are you going to use?
Are you going to use CBC or
are you going to use GCM?
What type of key do you want?
After you create those keys,
you then need to manage them.
You need to set up your
own rotation schedule.
own revocation schedule.
You need to be responsible
for making sure
that they're always online.
And each time you
update those keys,
you have to restart your
Kubernetes API server,
potentially causing downtime.
As I said, you have to
rotate them on your own.
You have to update that config.
And if you're trying to get
rid of old encryption keys,
you actually have to
re-encrypt all of your secrets.
Another drawback
is that many of you
might be in organizations
or regulatory requirements
where you're relying on
HSMs to achieve PCI or HIPAA
compliance.
And there's no way with the
Kubernetes 1.7 encryption
provider configuration to
leverage a hardware security
module.
You can't leverage an HSM.
So that was a non-starter
for some of those customers
who were depending on that.
And most importantly,
as I already said,
the biggest drawback is
that those encryption keys
are stored in plaintext
in the file system.
So from a threat
modeling perspective,
we haven't actually increased
our security posturing
by very much.
The keys are still
available in plaintext.
And because the attacker
could just get the keys
and decrypt the data,
it's effectively
an [? O ?] of N operation to get
the plaintext data out of ETCD.
So Kubernetes 1.10 provides a
much more secure solution using
a new kind of secrets
provider, KMS.
In this model,
Kubernetes delegates
encryption to a third
party campus provider
like Google Cloud
or HashiCorp Vault.
So let me show you
what that looks like.
Again, it's the same
encryption configuration.
But instead of specifying
the keys directly
in this encryption
configuration, which
lives on disk, we instead
specify the plugin and the Unix
socket where that
plugin resides.
We load that [? out ?] the
same way that we did before,
but now there's a third
party system in our flow.
We have our secret data.
Our secret data goes
to the API server.
The API server hits the
encryption configuration.
The encryption configuration
then makes a unix socket call
to, in the case of Google Cloud
KMS, the Google Cloud APIs
to encrypt or decrypt this data.
Google Cloud KMS then
returns encrypted cipher text
which is then stored in ETCD.
So even if an attacker has
access to the master nodes,
those encryption
keys are maintained
by an external system.
An attacker would have to
compromise both the master
nodes, ETCD, and the
third party KMS system
in order to be able to
decrypt those values offline.
But that might
sound complicated.
Right.
Like that's a lot of things.
And that interaction with Unix
sockets and file permissions,
that sounds difficult. But
the community has already
built a few of these for us.
So there is an open source
Google Cloud KMS plugin
that Alex actually worked on.
He's going to talk a little
bit about it in a second.
There's one for Azure.
There's one for AWS.
And there's one for
HashiCorp Vault.
So the communities and the
various special interest groups
are working hard to make sure
that your favorite secrets
management solutions
and your favorite KMS
providers are supported
as external KMS plugins
for Kubernetes.
Now if you are on Google
Cloud specifically,
we actually just
launched a feature
into beta that does
all of this for you.
It is so easy that
I actually thought
the PM was lying to me
when she showed it to me.
It was like, it just
can't be this easy, Maya.
There's no way.
But it actually is just as easy.
So this is a gcloud command.
There's an associated API call.
You give it three
pieces of information
when you create your cluster.
You give it the KMS key
location, the KMS key ring,
and the KMS key.
You're telling GKE, the
Google Kubernetes engine,
please encrypt my secrets
with this Cloud KMS key.
And all of that setup
and all of those things
I showed you before, that's
all done for you automatically.
But this begs an
interesting question,
which is, how does
Kubernetes get permission
to talk to the KMS provider
in the first place?
There has to be some
exchange authentication.
And this is where cloud
providers have an advantage,
because cloud providers
offer identity and access
management as a first class
part of their product portfolio.
So IAM solves that first
secret problem or the last mile
problem.
We delegate privilege
and access management
to the cloud provider's IAM.
And then we have a nice
separation of concerns.
The ETCD nodes don't need IAM
permission to talk to KMS.
So even if someone
has access to the VM
on which ETCD is
running, they don't
have permission to
talk to Cloud KMS,
because ETCD doesn't need that.
Only the Kubernetes
API server does.
So with that, I'd like
to invite Alex back
on stage to talk a little
bit about how this works
under the hood on
GKE and the way
that we do application
layer encryption.
So please give it up for Alex.
[APPLAUSE]
ALEX TCHERNIAKHOVSKI:
Thank you, Seth.
So Seth is very
convincing, so I don't even
think I need to be here anymore.
But I guess I need
to prove something
that it actually works.
So I'm hoping that by this
point in the presentation,
you are reasonably convinced
that storing secrets
in plaintext in ETCD, even
though the underlying disk is
encrypted, may not
be the best security
posture for your organization.
And you're wondering,
how do I enable
this additional
layer of encryption
or additional
layer of protection
when I'm running Kubernetes
in Google Kubernetes Engine?
So I will show
this in this demo.
It's a two step process.
The first step is we need to
create cryptographic keys.
We need to create cryptographic
keys in Cloud KMS.
You will find cryptographic
keys in the security subsection
of Google Cloud Platform.
When you land there,
you will notice
there is a concept
of key rings that
is introduced by Cloud KMS.
Key rings are analogous to
directories in the file system.
You can group together logically
related keys and, for example,
apply IAM policy at the
key ring level as opposed
to managing individual keys.
What you will also notice is
that key ring's allocation
specific.
They attach to a
specific location.
And it is important
point for us to know,
because our Kubernetes
cluster will need
to communicate with Cloud KMS.
And basically, whenever--
and we want that connection
to be as quick as possible.
So you want to [? co-locate ?]
your Kubernetes clusters
and your cloud KMS keys
in the same region.
OK.
So let me create a key.
Let's try to find
a meaningful name.
And you know what, the
defaults are just fine for us.
Before I hit Create,
the only thing
I will point out to make
the previous discussion
about key rotation a
little bit more concrete
is this parameter
here, rotation period,
which is by default 90 days.
But you can see that you can
set it to whatever makes sense
to your organization.
OK.
So let me go ahead
and click Create.
All right.
So that takes care of
the prerequisite work.
And now I'm ready to switch
to Kubernetes engine.
And I will create my cluster.
In order to enable
this [? officially, ?]
we need to expand availability,
networking, security,
and additional features section.
And I need to scroll down
to security subsection
and check Enable Application
Layer Encryption.
So just a quick
note on terminology.
In this talk, we use the
term ETCD level encryption
quite a bit.
And I think it's a
very pragmatic way
of thinking about it.
But the reality is that
ETCD is an implementation
detail in Kubernetes.
Kubernetes is designed to be
agnostic to the configuration
database.
So for that reason, we decided
to have a more generic name
for this feature.
So hopefully this will help you.
When you're reading
documentation on the feature,
you will see the term
application layer
encryption as opposed to
ETCD level encryption.
So now that I check
this option, you
can see that the UI team
has done a great job.
And what the UI has done
for me in the background
it enumerated all the
keys in that project
that meet the requirements
for this feature.
So I only have one.
So I'll go ahead
and select that.
And this is another
interesting thing
is that I get a warning here
that some IAM permissions are
missing on the key.
And I will explain what
those IAM permisssions are
and why do we need them when
we go back to the slides.
But for now, just say that
the Kubernetes service agent
account needs encrypt/decrypt
privileges on those keys.
And I have this.
All I need to do is just
click this grant button.
And that problem
is now resolved.
All that I need to do now at
this point is just hit Create.
And while the cluster
is spinning up,
I would like to switch
back to the slide
and talk about the feature
under the hood a little bit.
Thank you.
So let's review the
components involved.
Let's review the
components involved
in the encryption process.
However, this time we'll
go over [? those ?]
components from the threat
modeling point of view.
To better reason about
the threat model,
we will classify
components involved
as either volatile, everything
above the dotted line,
or persistent, everything
below the line.
So the persistent resources.
We assume that attackers
have full access to anything
on a persistent drive.
For the sake of
argument, let's assume
that attackers were able to get
a copy of the Kubernetes master
VM.
Of course, the main
point of interest for us
is the ETCD data file.
However, we are not
limited to-- we are not
assuming that attackers
have access only
to the ETCD data file.
Anything on that
persistent drive
which may help attackers to
decrypt secrets also fair game.
We need to protect
against those scenarios.
So this introduces the what
I call last mile problem.
And Seth mentioned Seth calls
it the first secret problem.
But they all point
to the same thing.
When you look at the diagram,
it becomes fairly obvious
that KMS plugin needs to
authenticate to Cloud KMS
service.
So this implies that
KMS plugin needs
to have some sort of
credential in order
to negotiate an auth token
to present to Cloud KMS.
Like pretty much everything
else in Google Cloud,
we use auth protocol
in order to--
for authentication purposes.
So what if an attacker--
what if we persisted
the credential
or the resulting token to disk?
Well, in this case,
attackers would actually
have everything they need in
order to decrypt our secrets,
because they have access to
the protected ETCD data file
but they also have a token
or [? its ?] credential
to speak with Cloud KMS.
And Cloud KMS, by virtue
of being a cloud service,
obviously is accessible
over public internet.
So it's important to make
sure that we are not leaking--
well, I'm jumping ahead.
Sorry.
So the core design objective is
to ensure in our threat model
that it is OK for attackers to
have access to the ETCD data
file, but they should
not have access
to anything else
that would allow
them to bootstrap communication
with the Cloud KMS.
And in the next
several slides, I
will explain how we
met this objective.
This will be a review
for most of you.
But I wanted to make sure
that we are on the same page.
And I wanted to explain
some concepts about GKE.
Most of you probably
already know this,
but please allow me a
couple of minutes here.
So you probably already
know that Google
handles all of the details of
running Kubernetes masters.
Kubernetes masters
reside in Google
managed infrastructure in
Google managed projects.
However, a less known
fact is that when
you enable GKE API
in your project,
a service account, which
we refer to as Kubernetes,
[? is ?] Kubernetes
service agent account
is created somewhere else in
Google managed infrastructure.
And that service account is
granted some IAM privileges
in the customer project.
Well, why?
Well, when we think about the
process of creating a cluster,
GKE needs to perform
operations such as create
a virtual machine,
create a firewall rule,
create a persistent disk.
Obviously, all of
these operations
require a security context.
And yes, it is through
this service account
that GKE accesses resources
in your customer projects.
OK.
So that was just a
review to set the plane
for the next discussion.
So what about Cloud KMS keys?
How do we access those?
Well, you saw in the
demo that the expectation
is that you customers create
those keys ahead of time.
And you grant the
encrypt/decrypt privileges
on those keys to Kubernetes
service [? agent ?] account.
You saw me just clicking
that button and the UI
fixed that for me.
That was kind of magic.
But you can certainly do
this in different ways.
For example, you can go
into the Cloud KMS UI
and just use IAM and
grant permissions there
or you can use gcloud commands.
You may be thinking, that
was a very simple operation
to create that key.
Why couldn't you just embed this
into the [? classic ?] creation
process?
Well, we certainly
considered doing this
but decided against this.
We felt that giving
GKE the ability
to create this very
security sensitive artifacts
in your projects would give
GKE way too much power.
And we also felt that that
would break the segmentation
between GKE and Cloud KMS.
Therefore we expect that you
customers create those keys
and allow us, GKE, to
use them for the purposes
of this feature.
The remaining piece
of the puzzle,
how does KMS plugin
actually authenticate
to Cloud KMS service?
So this is done by communicating
with an internal token service,
which is again
managed by Google.
And the internal token
service requires KMS plugin
to prove that it is a
member of a cluster that
is linked to the
corresponding service account.
So for example, I'm
trying to negotiate access
to crypto key--
not me, the Cloud KMS
trying to negotiate access
to that crypto key.
And what token service
will try to figure out
are you in fact running
on that cluster that
is linked to that service
account, the Kubernetes service
agent account.
And if you can prove
this to me, then I
will give you that token.
So we don't have time to go
through the proof of membership
protocol here.
But it is sufficient to say
that this token service has
full knowledge about
the master components.
And it can make that decision
of whether granting or denying
the access based on the prior
information in the database
that it has access to.
So assuming that everything
went fine, token service was
satisfied with the fact
that KMS plugin runs
in the right cluster,
it will grant this auth
token which is now KMS
can present to the encrypt
or decrypt-- sorry.
It can present to the
Cloud KMS service.
This token service,
this auth token,
is not persistent to disk.
We store it in memory.
If the KMS plugin
is rebooted, we'll
just go through the
same dance once again.
But at no time we actually
restore it to disk.
And that is how we actually--
and that is how we met
our initial objective.
We do not store
credentials on disk.
And we do not store
the resulting tokens
to disk, which allows us to
meet our threat model where
all that hackers get is just
ETCD with encrypted secrets.
OK.
This is my last slide.
And I'm going to change the
subject just a little bit.
And I want to talk
about how to run
Cloud KMS plugin outside GKE.
So even though we
hope that you're
using GKE to run Kubernetes,
we understand that some of you
may be using Google
Compute Engine
VMs as the infrastructure
to run Kubernetes.
And the question is can we
ship the same security contract
when running outside GKE?
And the answer is yes.
It just simply the catch is
there is simply more work
to manage and set it up.
Cloud KMS plugin is
developed in open source.
You have a link here
to the repository.
And in the same repository,
you will find instructions
on how to set up Cloud KMS
plugin outside Kubernetes
when running on GCE.
Architecturally, it
looks very similar,
the core difference
being, of course,
that there is no Kubernetes
service agent account.
Instead, we rely on the service
account in the security context
of which runs the GCE VM.
You probably know that
when you create the GCE VM,
you can associate it
with a service account.
And by virtue of
this association,
GCE VM can impersonate
that service account.
So you pretty much
follow the same process.
You create a service account.
You create keys.
You grant service account
encrypt/decrypt privileges
on the key, and then
you start the GCE VM
in the security context
of that service account.
From that point on,
everything looks the same.
But it's just a
little bit more work.
And then you have to manage
it from that point on.
This is all I had.
With that, I would like to
invite Seth back on stage.
[APPLAUSE] Thank you.
Thank you.
SETH VARGO: All right.
Thank you, Alex.
But you work on security, right?
ALEX TCHERNIAKHOVSKI: Yeah.
SETH VARGO: So
there is one thing
that I learned is that
you never trust someone
who works in security products.
So how do we know you just
didn't fake that GKE thing?
Like how do we know that
application layer encryption is
even enabled on that?
ALEX TCHERNIAKHOVSKI: Oh, you
mean like the cluster actually
failed to create [? itself ?]
and I just didn't show that?
SETH VARGO: Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]
That could have been a
recording for all we know.
ALEX TCHERNIAKHOVSKI: Right.
Could we switch
to the demo again?
All right.
So the cluster did create,
which is a good sign.
All right.
But on a serious note,
that was the cluster
that we created a
few minutes ago.
So what is the visual indication
that you have a cluster
with that feature enabled?
So if you scroll
down a little bit,
you will see application
layer encryption.
And you can see it's enabled.
And here again you have a link.
If I follow this link,
it should take me
to the cryptographic key that
we created in the first step.
And here's where you can manage
the key, like for example,
the options available to
me are disable, destroy.
And Seth talked about
crypto-shredding.
If I wanted to kill that cluster
right now, all I need to do
is just destroy that key.
And essentially, it will not be
possible to create new secrets
on that cluster,
which I'm not sure
if I recommend this option.
I would probably just delete
the cluster in the first place.
But it is something that
you need to be aware of.
Anyways, I think--
did I prove it enough?
SETH VARGO: I have another
question for you though.
I'm going to put
you on the spot.
What if I have an
existing cluster?
Can I enable this on
an existing cluster?
ALEX TCHERNIAKHOVSKI: Yes.
Version specific though.
SETH VARGO: Oh, OK.
ALEX TCHERNIAKHOVSKI:
So we need--
we were waiting for some
updates in Kubernetes 113,
which allow us to
enable encryption
on existing clusters.
SETH VARGO: OK.
So as long as they're
running Kubernetes version
113 or later, you can
enable this on an existing--
ALEX TCHERNIAKHOVSKI:
That is correct.
SETH VARGO: Super cool.
Thanks, Alex.
If we go back to
the slides, please.
So we know that many of
you might be on prem.
You might be on another
called provider.
You might be doing
all of those things.
And you may already be
using a secrets management
tool like HashiCorp Vault.
So what if you're not on a cloud
provider Kubernetes service?
What if you're not on GKE?
What if you're not
entirely on GKE?
How can you protect yourself
against these types of attacks
where an attacker has
access to the ETCD backup
or an online ETCD database?
So you can leverage something
like HashiCorp Vault
to do this.
And it looks very similar to
what we already described.
So instead of
Google Cloud KMS, we
throw HashiCorp
Vault in the mix.
Specifically, we're using
HashiCorp Vault's cloud transit
back end, transit secrets
engine if you will.
The secrets engine is very
similar to a Cloud KMS
provider.
It has key management, rotation,
upgrading, downgrading,
et cetera.
It looks very similar to
what we described before.
The secret data is given to
the Kubernetes API server.
The Kubernetes API server then
delegates to the encryption
configuration.
The encryption configuration
then makes an API call
to something like
HashiCorp Vault.
The Vault transit backend
encrypts that data or decrypts
that data before it is
written back to ETCD.
So this is a great
opportunity if you
have multi-cloud strategy.
If you're leveraging multiple
clouds, multiple Kubernetes
clusters, this gives you a
very consistent way in order
to encrypt your secrets with
an existing secrets management
solution.
So very quickly,
I'd like to show you
what that looks like and show
you what the data in ETCD
looks like if it's encrypted
with something like HashiCorp
Vault or Google Cloud KMS.
Can we jump over to the
lappy toppy, please?
Cool.
So what I'm going to do
here is create secret vault.
So I have a minikube cluster,
the same one I had before.
But this time I added
an encryption provider
configuration to encrypt
secrets with HashiCorp Vault
before writing them to ETCD.
I could have done this Google
CLoud KMS or even another cloud
provider's KMS but I'm using
Vault locally to showcase
a third party open source tool.
Now I'm going to go ahead and
try to access that secret.
And you'll notice that we don't
get back the plain text data.
So even though I had the same
secret, username seth vargo,
password secret in leet,
this is what I get back.
I get back Kubernetes
encryption prefix,
the Vault key that
I'm using, and then
a bunch of data that my terminal
can't even print for you.
So if an attacker
has access to ETCD
or has access to
this plaintext data,
this is what they would get.
They don't get the
plaintext secrets.
They get this encrypted data.
And again, this
example here shows
what it looks like on HashiCorp
Vault. If on Google Cloud
you had access to the
underlying ETCD data,
it would look very
similar to this
if you were using
application layer encryption.
The plaintext data would
not be available to you.
So we jump back to
the slides real quick.
So to conclude, Kubernetes 1.10
and later introduce some really
great features that make it easy
to be secure with Kubernetes
secrets.
Always use layered encryption.
Use full disk encryption,
operating system encryption,
combined with something like
application layer encryption.
Rotate your keys regularly,
both on a schedule
and in the event
of a data breach.
Leverage envelope encryption.
It's an incredibly scalable
way to perform encryption.
And fourth, use an
external KMS provider,
whether that's something
like Google Cloud KMS
or something like
HashiCorp Vault
as it requires an
attacker to compromise
multiple systems in
order to gain access
to that plaintext data.
[MUSIC PLAYING]